[Applause]
all right i know why you're happy
tonight america got rid of that
not-so-fresh feeling
that's right joe biden joe biden was
sworn in as america's 46th president i
think we have now and i would like to
say
america give yourselves a round of
applause for pulling off a semi-peaceful
transition of power how about that
semi-peaceful people
and boy it's been three days now with
the new president he has not yet
insulted anyone no did not have a
meltdown on twitter
did not betray the nation that he works
for
it's nice to have a president who's
hinged
pinched we have hinged back
no i can't get used to it i'm still
writing word doomed on my checks
[Laughter]
so i i thought the inauguration uh did
you watch that i thought that came off
quite well uh dignified uh
enough pageantry you know to remind us
that we are getting back to normal some
nice touches
uh garth brooks sang amazing grace and
uh
by the looks of him he rarely misses a
chance to say grace
[Laughter]
he's the theme i know if you
notice of the inauguration was america
united
at least i think there was it was hard
to read the banner behind the razor wire
[Laughter]
and then uh the new president went in
got his first intelligence brief
which describes the state of the country
and he read the first paragraph and went
uh see if the guy in the viking helmet
still wants it
[Laughter]
uh so that all happened and then earlier
in the day of course the whiny little
[ __ ]
left um that's right bye propecia
and uh
to quote melania thank god that's over
with
no melania was very comforting to donald
he was in a bad mood but she said it's
okay dear
as you get older it's harder to achieve
insurrection
[Laughter]
now melania looked happy there on on the
day they'd left her she left
washington d.c wearing a somber black
outfit
and then she arrived in florida dressed
like she was on her way to [ __ ] jimi
hendrix
[Laughter]
um but boy
donald trump boy the last couple of
months left graciously didn't he
oh yeah you know trump fans i got to
tell you trump fans out there
among the liberals i was pretty much the
nicest one to you i always said you can
hate trump
but you can't hate all the people who
like it but i gotta say your boy
total class that's what what must you
people love the most
is class from not being man enough to
admit that he lost the election to then
telling the mob
i'm with you i think it runs back into
the house
to not attending the inauguration class
all the way this [ __ ] i'm so
glad he did not
i'm so glad he did not attend the
inauguration because you know
he's the ex-husband you don't want to
invite to the wedding because he'll
stand up and yell she's a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
just had to get that out of my system
but
but you know his followers now the trump
you know q anon they don't know what to
think now
because they were told to follow the
plan that trump would prevail and win a
second term and then go after the satan
worshiping pedophiles
and that didn't happen and you know it's
not like the internet to lie
[Laughter]
so if you guys believe that i have some
very bad news about horny milfs right in
your neighborhood
really bad news on uh
and if you're one of these q anon people
who are you know the scales have lifted
now and you're saying boy it's hard to
believe i fell for all that
it's nice to know that finally there's
something you found hard to believe
but i think you know i think people in
america just basically unhappy and then
they find
political reasons why i mean antifa the
other side of it
they were up yesterday in two days ago
in portland smashed windows after biden
was inaugurated burned to biden flag
i they don't like him either i love gen
z they will binge watch 30 episodes of a
tv show before it gets good
but they'll only give biden one day
i mean they they rioted when trump
was in office now they're writing when
biden's there i think some people just
don't like windows
you